Transcriber: Aya Mokhtar
المدقّق: Nada Hamdy
[TEDx ERU]
صباح الخير جميعًا
[TEX ERU الطبيب إبراهيم عبده إبراهيم]
إبراهيم عبده 57357 صيدلي إكلنيكي
أعمل منذ عام 2009
وتخرجت في جامعة عين شمس عام 2009
قصة صيدلي العمليات
ماهذا! هل يوجد صيدلي في غرفة العمليات؟
هل من المهم وجود الصيدلي في غرفة العمليات؟
هل سيُحدث وجوده فرقًا؟
أشك في ذلك.
يوجد طبيب التخدير وأطباء الجراحة لكن
هل الصيدلي له قيمة؟
هل له دور داخل غرفة العمليات؟
يوجد أطباء التخدير من أجل الأدوية
ماذا بعد؟
كانت التجربة الأولى عام 2013
".You are worth it go and change it"
"أنت تستحق اذهب وقم بتغيير."
عندما بدأت الفكرة كانت تحديًا في عام 2013
كانت الإدارة تلح في رغبتها
بتواجد صيدلي بالعمليات لعله يحدث فارقًا.
طوال الوقت لم نكن مقتنعين بأن وجود صيدلي
بغرفة العمليات قد يكون مهمًا في أي خطوة.
كقسم كبير من العمليات والتخدير والجراحين
وهم أُناس أقوياء جدًا فعلًا،
ونتيجة الكثير من الإلحاح كما نقول
تواجدنا لمدة أسبوع واحد فقط كتجربة،
كان ما لدي من معلومات أننا سنقوم بالتجربة
لمدة أسبوع واحد لنرى ما ستحدثه التجربة،
هل سيحدث الصيدلي فارقًا أم لا؟
وبعد ذلك فإن ثبُت احتياجه تواجد
وإلا عاد مكانه مرة أخرى،
وفي الحقيقة تم إخباري أنني حتمًا لن أستمر
إنها فقط تجربة من أجل إلحاح الادارة
أو لنرى الفكرة عمومًا لكن لن يحدث فارقًا
أو شيئًا زائدًا عن المعتاد.
أتذكر أنه كان أسبوعي الأول
أو الثاني بالعمليات،
وجدت طبيبًا أو أحد أفراد التمريض يخبرني
أن أحد الجراحين في حاجة لي بإحدى الغرف،
فذهبت، طبعًا لم أكن خائفًا من الدم
فقد اعتدته،
لكن أن يحتاجني جراح
في وقت العملية بأسبوعي الثاني!
دخلت إليه فأخبرني: اقترب يا إبراهيم
سأختصر لك القصة،
كان هذا الطفل يعاني من ورم بالطحال فأزلناه
لكن فوجئنا بوجود الكلية خلفه
ملتف حولها شريان محدثًا تشنجًا،
والآن لدي حلان، أنت صيدلي إكلينيكي
بدأت العمل معنا حديثًا،
فإن كان لديك حل فلتقله، إذا لم يكن لديك
حل، حلي الجراحي هو أن أستأصل الكلية،
ويجب أن نقوم بإزالتها فورًا
ففكرت يا إلهي ما هذا؟ حقًا؟
ثم سألته هل من الممكن أن تسمح لي بدقيقة؟
فأخبرني: لا أمامك 30 ثانية.
يجب أن تجد حلًا خلال 30 ثانية.
30 ثانية! حسنًا فلأفكر بهدوء،
حسنًا، هل إذا أخبرته باسم دواء بابفرين
سيكون كافيًا؟
لدي حالة vasoconstriction (ضيق بالأوعية)،
إذن يمكنني إعطاؤه
vasodilator (موسع للأوعية)
حسنًا سأعطيه بابفرين
لكن ليست هذه المعلومة كافية بالنسبة له
فقمت ببعض الحسابات داخل عقلي،
يزن الطفل 10 كجم ويحتاج لجرعة بابفرين
يُحسب 1.5 ملجرام لكل كيلوجرام، وزن المريض
10 كيلو، إذن فهو يحتاج 15 ملجرام،
الأمبول كل سنتي مربع به 30 ملجرم
إذن أحتاج إلى إعطائه نصف سنتي،
فجأة بعد انتهاء الـ 30 ثانية قمت بإخباره،
"دكتور نحتاج لأخذ نصف سنتي من البابفرين
وحقنه مباشرةً في الكلية."
بعد أن تم الحقن استأذنته
"دكنور أنا مضطر للذهاب"
فأخبرني لا بل ستنتظر حتى نرى
فإن لم يُحدث نتيجة ستشاهد إزالة الكلية
ظللت بجانبه حتى مرت دقيقة، دقيقتان،
الحمد لله عادت الدورة الدموية للكلية،
فبدأت بالعمل مرة أخرى، عندما خرجت
كانت تلك أول حالة طارئة أتعامل معها،
ففكرت "لا، هذا كثير، هل يعقل؟
سأعيش هكذا!"
هذه كانت القصة الأولى.
ما هو مفهومي الخاص؟
مفهومي الخاص هو أني أعمل مع مرضى ومع أطفال
Human are the core of the universe
(الإنسان هو جوهر الكون)
صديقي زياد، زياد كان طفلًا من العمليات
كان عندنا وقام بإجراء عملية،
ولمعلوماتكم هذا الطفل دخل للعملية وحدث
أن قلبه توقف، توقف قلبه لأكتر من 45 دقيقة
كنا نعمل عليه والحمد لله قد أحدث فارقًا
لدينا وجاء بعد سنة وقمنا بأخذ تلك الصورة،
قالت والدته لقد سمعت بما
فعلت حضرتك بالداخل
أو أقصد كم شاركت في
الجرعات والأدوية وما إلى ذلك
فكنت أدعو لك.
.Human are the core of universe
(الإنسان هو جوهر الكون.)
الآن لن أحتاج لأكثر من هذا
لا أريد أكثر من هذا، هذا ما كنت أحتاج إليه
هكذا تسير الأمور.
حسنًا، أول ما بدأنا عندما
بدأت في عام 2013.
أول ما قيل لي "إبراهيم، في أي عام
ولدت يا بني" ولدت في عام 1986.
فقال حسنًا أصغِ إليّ: "عام 1986
كنت أتممت رسالة الدكتوراه بفرنسا"
قلت له: "حسنًا شكرًا يا دكتور"،
وأكمل: "حسنًا عام 1986،
كنت قد تزوجت للمرة
الثانية أو الثالثة لا أتذكر يا إبراهيم،
أنا آسف، 1986 - هل ستعمل إذن معنا؟
أقصد هل أنت موجود؟ أنا آسف، أنا؟ نعم.
حسنًا، نحن متميزون بمجالنا جدًا
نعمل منذ أكثر من 30 سنة،
هل ترى أن صيدليًا قد يُحدث فارقًا لدينا؟
نحن على دراية بالعمل وكيفية أداء كل شيء.
أسبوع واحد فقط ثم ستعود لمكانك من أجل
المنظر العام فقط ونرى ما يمكنك فعله معنا
لكنك ستعود لن تستمر أكثر من ذلك
قضيت أسبوعًا واحدًا أشاهد لا أتحدث أبدًا
أشاهد فقط وأجمع البيانات التي أحتاجها
ثم في النهاية، إن كان لديك ما تضيفه
أخبرنا به، قضيت أسبوعًا
بعد أسبوع أخبروني: "حسنًا، فرصة سعيدة يا
إبراهيم، خذ أرقام هواتفنا وأعطنا رقم هاتفك
وعُد، فأخبرتهم لا من الممكن أنني -
وجدت نقاط - نقاط تحسين
من الممكن أن أساعد بها المريض
داخل غرفة العمليات.
كم نقطة تظنون؟ إذا فكر أحدكم أن لديه
أسبوعًا ويجب أن يضع الوصف الوظيفي الخاص به
ويريد أن يضع نقاط تحسين، كم نقطة تظنون؟
فليخبرني أحدكم بأي رقم
كم وجدت؟ كم؟ 6؟ 6.
أعني ما فرصة احتياجي كصيدلي إكلينيكي بغرفة العمليات؟
قليخبرني أحدكم برقم آخر،
20، هناك من يقول 50، 110نقطة،
110 نقطة أحاول بها تحسين الجودة للمريض،
وكان هذا أول تحدٍ، ما هذا؟ أيعقل؟
هل يستطيع صيدلي أن يقوم بكل هذا؟
نعم، يوجد أمور أحتاج أن أتدخل بها.
الدواء، فأنا أكثر من يفهم في الدواء،
فيمكنني أن أتحدث عن الدواء بصورة أفضل
أو أن أصل إلى أن أُوصل فوائد الدواء
بأفضل طريقة للمريض. حسنًا فلنبدأ،
سنبدأ سويًا إن شاء الله.
أولًا، قمنا بتغيير التوجيهات
الخاصة بالمضادات الحيوية عند العمليات.
ما هو إذن المضاد الحيوى الخاص بنا؟
ولمعلوماتكم يوم أن غيرت تلك التوجيهات
أمسكت هاتفي وكنت أتصفح فيسبوك فأغقلته،
قمت بفتح هاتفي لعمل بحث فقط،
كانت هذه بدايتي، لم أبدأ في مكتبة، لم
أبدأ بجلوسي وسط الكتب،
لم أبدأ وأنا جالس في مؤتمر كبير، لا، كنت
جالسًا على أريكة منزلي في غرفة المعيشة
أتصفح فيسبوك، ثم فكرت في لحظة، ماذا بعد؟
حسنًا، ماذا يفترض بي أن أحتاج أن أفعل
في العمليات؟ هل من المفترض أن أسأل أحدًا،
أو أُرسل إلى أحد وأبدأ بالقراءة؟ حسنًا،
غدًا سوف أذهب إلى المكتبة،
لكن الأمر أنني لم أكن أدرك أن الحل بيدي.
قمنا بتغيير توجيهات المضادات الحيوية
أثناء العمليات، قمنا بتقليل معدل العدوى
بنسبة 21% من المرضى
بدلًا من حدوث عدوى سابقًا
بدأ معدل العدوى بالتغير بناءً على
هذه التوجيهات الجديدة
صار المرضى يقضون أقل فترة بالمستشفى
وقد تم ترجمة تلك النتائج لأموال
وفرنا للمستشفى - أو وفرت (صيدلي العمليات
للمستشفى) 8,242,067 جنية بالسنة.
ما هذا، أيعقل؟ نعم، من فتحي للهاتف فقط
أثناء جلوسي وأنا أريد البحث،
أريد الوصول لشيء ما سأتمكن من الوصول إليه.
الفكرة من القصة ليست المال بل الأرواح.
إنها حياة، فالعدوى مميتة والمكوث
بالمستشفى مميت، تتعب العائلة كلها،
فالمريض ليس مريضًا وحده،
إنه مريض بعائلة وهذه هي النقطة
ماذا تحتاج أن تفعل؟
الشيء الآخر الذي احتجت أن أفعله أو فعلته
هو الملاءمة الدوائية،
العديد من المشاكل بالنسبة لنا
مثلًا تجد الطفل أو أي شخص منا:
"غدًا سأذهب لإجراء عملية."
حسنًا انتبه فقد أخبرنا أطباء التخدير أنك
ستحتاج أن تصوم 12 ساعة،
حسنًا متى سأحتاج للصوم؟
سأمتنع عن كل شئ إذن لن أكل أو أشرب،
لكن ماذا عن أدوية القلب؟ أو أدوية الضغط؟
أدوية ال - أو اذا كان لدي صرع
مثلًا لا قدر الله؟
هل سأحتاج لتناول هذه الأشياء أم لا؟
انتبه فأنت تحتاج لتناولها.
يوجد سوء فهم في العالم كله
أو تحديدًا في مصر
أني إذا كنت صائمًا وكان لدي مرض في القلب
أو أى شيء فلن أتناول الدواء لأني صائم.
هذا الكلام خاطئ، استطعت زيادة الالتزام
بأدوية الصرع للمرضي، لـ 390 مريض.
أحدثنا فرقًا في 390 عملية،
390 عملية
قبل أن ندخل، كان لدى مريض سرطان في المخ،
ضبطنا أدوية الصرع الخاصة به
وتأكدنا أنه قد تناولها، لنقلل احتمالية
أن يحدث له صرع داخل العملية.
لمعلوماتكم إذا حدث صرع أثناء العملية
يتوفى المريض بكل بساطة.
بالنسبة لأدوية القلب
فقد أحدثنا فرقًا بالنسبة لـ 130 مريض
دخلوا و لم يتناولوا أدوية القلب
الخاصة بهم، فضبطنا أدوية القلب الخاصة بهم.
بالنسبة للمضادات الحيوية، تأكدت أن
128 شخصًا قبل أن يدخلوا غرفة العمليات،
تأكدت أن جميع مزارعهم على ما يرام.
الإعادات الخاصة بالمضادات الحيوية،
قمت بـ 173 عملية تابعتها أثناء العملية،
احتاجت إلى تناول المضادات الحيوية
مرة أخرى.
لمعلوماتكم جميعًا، هل أحتاج إلى النظر إلى
الحالات الحرجة فقط أثناء العملية؟
لا، أنت تتابع كل ما يخص المريض،
لأن كل لحظة أثناء العملية تشكل فرقًا.
تشكل كل دقيقة فرقًا، كل خطوة
يقوم الجراح بها تشكل فرقًا.
إذنا فيجب أن تتابع المريض
طوال الوقت أثناء العملية.
قمت باختبار الحساسية
لـ 28% من المرضى،
تأكدت أنه ليس لديهم حساسية لأدوية
قبل دخول العملية،
ووجدت أن 28% من المرضى
كان لديهم مشكلة،
وأصلحنا الأمر الحمد لله قبل دخولهم
بدأت أكون فريقًا بعد ذلك بسنة،
اقتنعت الإدارة: ما هذا؟ هنالك دور للصيدلي،
سيحدث الصيدلي فرقًا كبيرًا.
حسنًا، ما الذي تحتاج إليه،
بدأت أحاول أن أحضر الأدوية
أو المضادات الحيوية أو جميع أدوية التخدير
داخل غرفة العمليات،
فبدأت أول تجربة لتحضير أدوية العمليات
داخل غرفة العمليات.
أحدثت فارقًا كبيرًا معنا، كانت هذه أول تجربة،
حضرت في غرفة العمليات حتى الآن تقريبًا
13525 عملية.
(تصفيق)
أحدثنا فرقًا في كل لحظة فيها،
المضمون أني بدأت الفكرة في البداية
بأنني أريد فقط أن أصل لشيء ما،
كله أنني أخدم المريض فقط.
جاءت أول زيارة عندنا، أنا لم أكن أعلم
ما هي القصة، فجائني طبيب اسمه دوركينج كريج
وجيسون باركر، هذان الاثنان، هذان الاثنان
من جامعة كلية لندن (يو سي إل)
كلية الصيدلة.
عميد الكلية ورئيس الدراسات العليا،
كلية الصيدلة جامعة كلية لندن (يو سي إل)
ثالث أقوى كلية صيدلة في العالم.
والطبيب أسامة مسلم معروف، الطبيب
أسامة مسلم كان مسؤول تدريب في هارفارد.
فوجدتهم ذاهبين لزيارة قالوا نريد أن نرى
صيدلي العمليات، حسنًا.
ماذا تفعل يا إبراهيم، فجلست وأحضرنا جميع
الأوراق، أنا أقوم ب 1، 2، 3، 4.
فأوقفني فجأة "هل هذا حقيقي؟"،
الطبيب دوركينج كريج
عميد كلية الصيدلة بجامعة كلية لندن
(يو سي إل)، نعم، هذا حقيقي.
كنت متخيلًا أنني سأجد أى صيدلي في مصر
يصرف دواءً على النافذة بالخارج
فقط ليس أكثر من هذا،
ولكن هل وصلنا إلى تلك المرحلة؟
نعم، حسنًا من أين أتيت بهذا الكلام؟
رتبت الأشياء التي أحتاج أن أفعلها
وبحثت عن كيفية الوصول لها،
وأصل إلى المعلومات نفسها وقمت بها.
"إبراهيم أريد إخبارك أنه من المفترض أن
الاتفاقية هي أن نأخذ صيادلة من عندكم،
ونرسلهم جامعة كلية لندن إلى (يو سي إل)،
أستأذنك إذا كنت متفرغًا أن نرسل أطباء من
يو سي إل للتدريب عندك في غرفة العمليات."
"هل تتحدث إليّ!، ما هذا، هل هذا أنا؟
57 - أنا - أنا إبراهيم!
نعم، إذا كنت متفرغًا، فقلت يمكن أن تأخذني
إلى هناك لأدربكم ليس هناك مشكلة، حسنًا.
جاءني صيادلة من البرتغال فورًا،
وأرداوا صيدليًا من صيادلة العمليات
وسألوني هل من الممكن أن نتدرب لديك؟
حسنًا، وقاموا بالتدريب.
وجدتهم يتصلون بي ويقولون نريد
وصفًا وظيفيًا للمرضى في البرتغال لنطبقه عندنا.
من أجل صيادلتنا الإكلينيكيين.
هل هذا حقيقي؟ حسنًا.
حسنًا هيا بنا.
جاءني صيادلة من أسبانيا،
وجاءني صيادلة من كرواتيا،
وجاءني بعد ذلك صيادلة من موزمبيق،
وجاءني صيادلة من السودان
ومدغشقر وأماكن كثيرة جدًا.
وجاء صيادلة، ثلاثة صيادلة من أمريكا،
كانوا صيادلة إكلينيكيين بغرفة العمليات.
وبدؤوا بالتحدث معي، وجاء صيادلة
من دستور الأدوية الأمريكي (يو إس بي)
وتحدثوا أيضًا معي، من وقت من الأوقات جاء
مدير المستشفى الطبيب شريف أبو النجا.
وقال لي: "إبراهيم، نريد أن نعلم الناس
من هو الصيدلي الإكلينيكي،
ما الذي من المفترض أن الصيدلي الإكلينيكي
يفعل؟ فبدأنا برغبتنا في القيام بحملة،
وهذه هي قصة الإعلان،
وهذه من الأشياء التي قمنا بها.
هناك صوت، هناك صوت -
[إعلان] (موسيقى)
[جمعية أصدقاء المبادرة القومية ضد السرطان
الإنسانية ضد السرطان،
مشروع الصيدلة الإكلينيكية
بالتعاون مع وزارة الصحة والسكان]
كانت حملة هدفها توعية المجتمع بدور الصيدلي
الإكلينيكي، وكم أحدث فرقًا في خدمة الصحة.
رنا صديقتي، كانت رنا في يوم من الأيام
محجوزة عندي في الرعاية
بعد أن قامت بعملية في المخ، بقيت رنا عندنا
في الرعاية أكثر من 60 يومًا،
كانت نسبة أن تعيش شيئًا ضئيلًا، كان لديها
عدوى قوية، رنا الحمد لله قد شُفيت وأكملت
في هذا اليوم، وجدت رنا ووالدها وقال لي
أريد فقط أن أخبر حضرتك بشيء
رنا قادمة لا تريد أى شيء غير أن تحتضنك فقط
وتذهب ليس أكثر، ماذا سأحتاج أكثر من هذا؟
هذه هي القصة،
ما الذي أحتاج أن أصل إليه في الدنيا؟
هل وظيفتي أن كل ما أحتاجه
هو أن أقوم بوظيفتي؟
أنتج الشيء الذي سأقوم به؟
تحتاج إلى أن تسأل نفسك سؤالًا واحدًا فقط.
لم أتيت؟ ماذا فعلت اليوم؟
ماذا فعلت للمستقبل؟
ماذا فعلت لحياتك؟ خذها قاعدة،
[لقد ولدت لتعيش فلا تعش لأنك ولدت،
لا تذهب في طريق الحياة
بل خذ الحياة في طريقك]
كان من الممكن أن أستسلم،
كان من الممكن أن أقول أنا صيدلي إكلينيكي
بغرفة العمليات ويمكن ألا أفعل أى شيء.
أنظر إلى الأدوية من الخارج فقط ولا أقوم
بأى شيء آخر وأمضي، لكن لا.
أحتاج أن - وجدت نفسي -
ألن أُسأل أمام الله؟
ألن أصل لشيء ما؟ يجب أن يكون لي قيمة
في يوم من الأيام، هذه هي القصة.
تحتاج إلى أن تنظر إلى نفسك
وتسأل نفسك: لم أنت موجود؟ وانتبه،
"أنت تستحق، اذهب وقم بتغيير."
[لإبراهيم عبده إبراهيم]، شكرًا جميعًا.
(تصفيق)
[TEDx ERU]